this girl that I like I think she's
pretty cute and she uh she's in the
anime so she kind of got me watching it
that's how it starts that's how it start
that's always how well so she's there
when you watch it no no oh okay I was
going to say that's hard yeah no no I'm
watching it by myself you get a bunch of
no look look look this part right
here welcome to a very important episode
of careful boys we got right here Mr
Anthony oh jitsukawa over there in the
special side we got Nick the ear we got
khen and we have k k special guest cam
special man [__] you yeah
you God damn and we got the coolest Joe
around thank you for being here with us
it
escalates we always get asked this
question and I um a lot of you guys have
sent it in the DMS over and over and I
thought why not answer it today you've
asked us what are our favorite
animes Ryan
anime cuz you are anime dude my actual
anime that I love are all from uh the '
80s and 90s really you're [__] old
why do you like the classic stuff
showing your age this is crazy but I I
never saw Dragon Ball Z cuz I didn't
have cable
what I didn't watch it I didn't watch it
when they did show it it was on
Saturdays so we were at church can't
watch TV on Saturday
I'm sorry I church on Sundays
oh you watch X-Men too H Dam can I guess
which one you watch is it cowboy bbop no
Neon Genesis evangelia no D what did you
watch did you watch uh YuYu Haku show I
know about it because they had a game
yuu Haku show yeah so I know about the
oh we talking about series here or
series are like mov do you do you
consider Miyazaki movies anim anime you
know what's funny I I do now I didn't
back then I I consider that like the
Disney movies of like yeah that is the
Disney movies even though it's like some
of the go [__] but my favorite ones in
terms of series I really loved maon koku
uh RMA RMA half and then also uh but
movies Wicked City demon city another
series I liked is record of lotus War
that's a that's a really that's almost
like watching Lord of the Rings like a
decade earlier but in anime form what
about Ninja scroll oh yeah that's a what
about Fist of the North Star hell yeah I
remember that I never watched all that's
brilliant too but yeah ninja skull
definitely was like that was a big thing
for sure did it make you want to be
ninja ninja skull was crazy dud you want
to be he wanted to be K you guys have
all seen ninja
SK no ninja skull that's worth watching
today because the artwork is is so still
so good yeah and it's it's pretty
graphic so oh I'm out I'm out yeah I
don't think actually don't watch it what
about Ghost in the Shell Ghost in the
Shell was yeah I liked it yeah but no uh
Angel cop was another really good one
that one's pretty crazy and some of
these things are also ironically good
where like as a kid you're watching it
and you think the dubbing is so funny so
that's part of it Golden Boy another
amazing anime series even if you watch
it in English dub it's really what's
that about uh it's about this guy who's
like super uh he quit his job and all he
wants to do is travel the world on his
bicycle and just experience life and he
gets into these situations where it's
the same formula he meets a girl who
like thinks he's repulsive hates him but
then he does something to improve their
life and he doesn't expect anything and
he leaves and he just keeps going and
they chase him to like cuz they're in
love with him so he has this huge trail
of women that like want him and he's so
that's so Funny's so unaware he's just
going through life like helping people
and then um by the end he gets in this
really bad Jam where he's trying to help
this uh last girl out and the only way
he can do is bring all the girls
together that he helped in the past to
like do this massive last favor and and
they have a massive
orgy he's also he's also a massive
pervert wa do you know you can never get
laid I feel anime his K is that his Kink
is that he can't resist uh if a girl's
been on the toilet he can't resist like
licking the seat just like oh my
God it's so much lighter when it's a
cartoon though how long ago was it how
long ago uh I believe the manga is from
the ' 80s or or early '90s and then the
anime is from the '90s D you know what's
crazy even today's like brand new anime
nothing has really changed the tropes
are always very similar it's always the
guy girls chasing after them they're
called harms but that's like a whole
category anime nasty can what was your
favorite what's your favorite head tie K
I don't have any favorites but um he
reads the fan fictions and the reddits
he likes the yayoi I think the most
recent one what is that I don't even
know what that is shut up don't act what
oh you're a freak you're going to get
the
Oscar come on what is it what is it look
it up y a y o i okay I'm not looking
that up I will look it up I'll look it
up yeah look it up you [__] [__]
what is it is it pornography no what the
heck like Yayo
manga I'm going incognito mode run this
dude no you don't need to do that no
one's even going to it has multiple
meanings by the way it's not not one
thing y a y o i and then write uh anime
or whatever yeah anime or Manga
afterwards I see this wait yo why is it
asking it's a it's a
genre I see TR to it's actually a very
popular genre I know what it is dude is
it is it what is it like it has to do
with kids it doesn't look like anything
no is it gay bro it has to do with kids
no it's not kids why is there kids stuff
on Nick's phone then I was like what do
you mean it has to do with kids so the
it me it doesn't it doesn't seem a genre
mostly written by women for women that
depicts homosexual relationships between
men yes okay there you go I was looking
at the colors and they're like all men
and stuff like that I was like wait is
about that's what I found really
fascinating cuz it it was really popular
and it's all gay romance but the it's
written it's written from
women by for women I thought that was
crazy
but I guess it's like lesbian porn
produced and directed by men well yeah
and it's cute supposed to be like really
yeah it's like really cute stuff cute
stories sense to answer your question my
favorite anime of all time is uh Samurai
champ PLO have you seen hell yeah that's
your favorite I wish they expanded on it
it was in the I think it was like early
2000s when it came out I'm not really
sure when but it was the first anime
that I saw that had hip-hop in it was
sick yeah they they they got feudal
Japan with hip-hop mixed together it was
a cool world also the artwork was so
swag is that the one with the black
samurai yeah no no no the black samurai
is Yas no no no but I mean Samurai
champo also has the do with the afro
afro right so that's okay I've seen it
never watch there's a black dude with
he's a samurai no that's Afro Samurai oh
that's AF Samurai wow Nick with yeah
with hip-hop music you're right well was
a black I thought it was going to be
with hip-hop you know the different is
there was no that's your abolute alltime
favorite alltime favorite that I've seen
probably like three four times like the
whole thing it's only
26 champu is actually a Japanese word
champu no Samurai champu it's like
saying um spaghetti western oh yeah cuz
cuz it means mix up yeah it's like they
they those old school Samurai um flicks
that's what a samurai champo is it's a
really good show though so like Seven
Samurai would be like a champu what's
the uh story line like give story
is there's these two samur and a girl
the girl's on a mission to find a a
samurai that smells like sunflowers
which we don't know who he is it's like
a big mystery but she needs the help of
these two like really good Samurai and
they're so good that they're always
fighting each other to try to kill each
other but they become friends they all
become friends and it's it's like a
whole like so it's like a whole okay got
they trying to find the [__] wait why
did she have to find them again I forgot
um I think it had to do with her
childhood and like her restaurant that
she was working in burned down in the
first episode so she's like you know
what I'm going to look for this guy cuz
she probably has no idea about her past
and she wants to know because that's the
only thing that you know she could
remember as a child right yeah yeah yeah
okay it's really it's really good I for
I haven't watched it in ages but have
you guys watched it anyone yeah yeah and
the two personalities of the Samurai are
like night and David yeah it's like blue
versus red everyone says it's a really
good I've heard that from so many people
they're like this is a really dop it's
really good I it's the same guy that
made made uh Cowboy bbop too if You'
seen that one that one really popular
work of art yeah I thought I thought you
were going to say one piece honestly I
just started one piece this year you're
not going to finish it dude 200 oh wow
okay you'll finish
it you're underestimating how nty years
no there's like a thousand and I think
you could actually watch it in like less
than a year and catch up it's not that
not that much yeah cuz each episode is
like 20 minutes oh it's really short and
there's a lot of you got to be dedicated
as [__] though but it's formatted like
people just leave it on though huh while
they just do stuff while they watch
other anime dude there's a reason why
there's a thousand episodes it's really
good people love one piece I think yeah
they just came out with a card game too
yeah yeah I'm playing it too hey what's
the one I play Yu-Gi-Oh oh that one's
good too I just played it the other day
that's funny what's the one that you
said you were watching right now uh Inu
Yasha Inu Inu
Yasha yeah I just started watching that
wait how what made you choose inas out
of everything else uh there's she a doll
there's this girl that I like
she uh she's in the anime so she kind of
got me watching it that's how it starts
that's how it starts that's always how
well so she's there when you watch it no
no oh okay I was going to say that's
hard yeah no no I'm watching it by
myself you can get a bunch of no look
look like this part right here
watch today's video is brought to you by
Lumi oh man look at this it smells so
good a one of my favorite flavors of
this is the Tangerine it's so good
smells I I'm acting like the camera
could smell it but it actually smells so
fresh M and if people put this on it
probably want to make me smell their
armpit so bad this one is called cool
cucumber I like this so much yes and you
guys ever do this where you poke the
eyes out of it and then you make a face
mask out of wet wipes oh so good
especially on a plane so as you can see
they have all kinds of deodorant
products they got the regular stick they
got the whole body deodorant so what
they make is not just for the armpit is
for anywhere and then they also have the
deodorant wipes and the cool thing about
it is it's invented by OBGYN and so you
know they deal with dirty stanky organs
all day long P so the cool thing about
it is it's meant for the whole body and
it's safe you could do it right here the
puss here the puss P there the puss P
there and anywhere you could go from tip
of the head down to the toe and it go
like
this cuz my stinkiest place is actually
my head really yeah stinks more than
anything else your scalp yeah oh you got
oily scalp I got old Asian man scalp I
think so this Lumi starter pack you see
right here is perfect for new customers
it comes with the Sol Stick deodorant
the cream tube deodorant two free
products of your choice like the mini
body wash and the deodorant wipes and
free shipping that's so good as a
special offer for listeners new
customers get $5 off a Lumi starter pack
with code OTR at Lumi podcast.com that
equates to over 40% % off your starter
pack when you visit Lumi podcast.com and
use the code OT T make you hate that
[__]
pause do you get it do you get what
happened let me go back I Just Dub
everything right now you know it's weird
cuz like growing up this is this was a
part of like Japanese childhood like we
would watch it all these not not all the
older ones so this the stuff that you
guys are quoting that's like by that
time I was too old well like guys that
would I would say people in Japan would
continue watching it right but for me
it's like I grew up watching have you
heard of doron yeah shinchan those are
all kid shinchan is that little kid with
the black hair and it's like fart jokes
yeah yeah yeah I'll watch that then the
American version they don't show him
painting elephant on his dick and
running around chasing his friends yeah
we're not ready for that kind of human
yeah but then it's edited right that's
shinan I remember that show what is he I
I've seen that this little guy oh yeah I
see that I just
remember what it was called yeah there's
like a lot of kid like jokes new jokes
whatever and then like
um yeah I think like at a certain point
it's it it was back then it was lame
that oh you're watching anime you're I
heard it was switched around like people
always told me that if you watch anime
in Japan you're way too nerdy and then
here it's like if you read the Manga
you're nerdy at that time yeah yeah so
that's why me and my friends were like
we we weren't getting we weren't into
that we got into other [__] like raving
and then drugs and whatever right that's
sick yeah it is fun right that's a lot
of fun so I think I missed out on that
whole thing and then like everybody here
is hella into it now so I know a lot of
the kid stuff like the yeah the Miyazaki
stuff we grew up on like Studio GI yeah
the yeah yeah would you say that Dragon
Ball Z is considered anime [__] yeah oh
yeah I always hear like a lot of people
saying like oh that and Dragon Ball Z is
not an so they just saying it literally
is a Japanese animation well they're
saying it's like the the Taco Bell of
Mexican food kind of no it's good dude
it's it's like absolutely like legendary
because of the guy that made it Aira
Toriyama he's like he's revolutionary
yeah he changed the whole game you know
what it is that was my favorite
basically the I think it's the Gateway
for Americans so that's why Pokemon and
Dragon Ball are the Gateway for
Americans so then they think that it's
just low like it's like eh yeah right
like they don't think it's the peak
because they're like oh yeah that's too
mainstream I know this [__] and I'm like
that's not true though in Japan like
it's the it's [__] dope legendary
it's also super influential for so many
other things that came after it right so
it's kind of like it it helped anime
kind of walk so then later it could run
kind of thing cuz the if you watch it
now it's like pretty dated because like
episodes would take like forever to get
to like the point it's like 12 episodes
to like think about a fight right and
then like charging up Tak like three or
four
episodes but they redid it and they made
a new series called Dragon Ball super
which I highly recommend it's [__]
fire the battle against the world of the
universe fights get like crazy mhm so
it's do they re they redid the whole
like animation no it's just a
continuation of Dragon Ball Z so it's
like they're all older now and all this
stuff but so that's the one to watch
definitely the one to watch highly Rec
that was my favorite as a kid but as a
kid couldn't even watch the [__]
things like I couldn't watch Dragon Ball
Z cuz I'd be like this taking forever
cuz I I remember my first introduction
was the comic book like the the ones
that was backwards and I was in like
second grade and I was I was like they
used have naked bulas in that all the
time it was weird for me to like read
from the other side cuz no one taught me
how to read it and I was going through
you're starting from the end I was like
I was like what you guys just got to go
right to left top to bottom no for sure
and I remember getting hooked on it and
I loved the lore and the stories and
everything but I never like watched any
of the episodes
I just watch like the movies every now
and then and then I just was into the
show honestly reading it is faster cuz
like you could just speed through like
commercial it's the 14 minute Mark of
the video where we have to start talking
about Naruto though like oh yeah yeah
yeah are you a really H narut denied
greatness personified dude I never
watched one episode of n you didn't
watch you went raving that's
WHYY did you guys sell me on
Naruto my question is how did it get so
famous in
America like I don't think it's as crazy
in Japan like it's it's known I do think
it was a very cultural phenomenon that
like people like really fell into like
like synonymous with um so many like
straight up Black Culture so many people
love n a lot of black people love n but
what but what happened to where it got
into like hip-hop and like it seemed
like people just recommended the [__]
out of it so it's it's not like play on
TV UFC fighters now are rocking it it's
cool I just think the characters are
like there's so such a variety of
characters that are so relatable that
everybody can pick their own favorite
cuz 90% of people who watch Naruto
Naruto is not their favorite character
no you know what I'm saying no one likes
that guy dude it's all it's all the
other guys it's all the other guys it's
the loving him to later
later I got to watch it then I need to
watch it too cuz I know everyone
everyone tells and I think my favorite
thing about Naruto in terms of like what
really got me like for real into it is
the fact that every bad person every
evil character in each Arc they were all
like they weren't just inherently evil
they like came from some their backstory
was like something that could help
Define why they became what they were
and it just made it so much more like
the depth was so much greater there was
always like a resolution where nuto
would somehow change them for the better
rather than just kill them yeah versus
just beat them but there's one character
that nobody likes who is it Sakura who's
that why why does no one like her she's
[__] nothing bro in comparison to
yeah exactly nothing even when she gets
her you know her top tier powers or
whatever she's just still trash she's in
the main team so Sasuke Sakura and
Naruto like they're they're team seven
right and there's like this funny ass
meme out there that's like like team
seven 100% power is like all three of
them and then it shows team seven at
99.9% power it's just Sasuke Naruto
she's just not in
it from what I heard it's like it's like
they're like schools battling each other
or something what's so they're all like
in different Villages there's like
they're from the hidden Leaf Village but
there's like the hidden Sand Village
there's like hidden rain Village
different like Villages elements I like
gangs yo I like when there's like
different you like gangs yeah you you'll
enjoy
it I just think there's so much
character depth in back story and and
then like this guy specifically well
this is Sasuke but this guy his brother
Itachi is like the ultimate character
ever I want to watch it I want I like it
like this guy's a guy who like kills his
entire [__] Clan but he's he does it
for the greater good it's [__] up so
he's like the dark guy that's hard to
justify right C off a whole he like he
walks in when he cuz he a little brother
he walks in when he's a kid and sees him
murdering his parents but it's like for
the greater goodness the hardest thing
you ever watched so he was that his does
he is that later on much later the story
The finding out that he murdered his
parents is early but you don't know why
so his entire thing the reason why he's
so badass and train so hard is cuz one
day he's like I'm going to kill my
brother oh that's tight and then he
probably finds out later wait it was for
good yeah yeah yeah oh I I love those
moments what about what about the Bruce
le guy his name is like rock rock what's
his deal so the reason why everybody's
favorite or a lot of people's favorite
is because he doesn't have Ninjutsu
Powers he can't do all like the cool
[__] stuff is it because he's
Chinese it's cuz of his hair dude but
but his TI you to his actual just
physical fighting is like bar none so
he's the best so like they they first
expose every character's weakness and
they highlight it and they make fun of
it and like all this stuff but it's only
like through enduring through the
weakness that you find a character's
real strength and I think that's why
it's so relatable lovable people end up
like really really like finding their
favorite character like my favorite
character is jariah he's called the
pervy sage just this [__] pervert
Yeah that's TI who who ends up being the
teacher of Naruto and he never becomes
like the golden hero he never becomes
like the hokago which is the leader even
though he's powerful enough he's the
Moshi yeah he just sacrif but he
sacrifices himself just to make sure
that like the the village and everything
like succeeds it's it's crazy that's a
good reference how many episodes is
Naruto like 300 oh there's only 300 well
like the first one I don't remember it's
like 150 or something Shen jump and then
like there's a threeyear gap where they
get older which was so fun because you
get older too so like everything the
theme of it becomes more mature and like
the missions become way crazier and
stuff like that and then like that's
another like it's called not to ship him
dude to to nail that timing with your
age must feel like pretty [__] bad
that's like Harry Potter huh like if I
did it now I'd be like I'm 43 look the
same you know the similar thing with one
piece is I heard the Creator was like 18
when he came out with like the whole One
Piece thing and so he was only 18 like
all of his his like like first few
seasons first four season or something
is like when he was young and then there
was like a big break and then they came
out with the newer the rest of the one p
oh wait wait the characters 18 or the
Creator the Creator oh wow and so so
later on his his like rest of the anime
arcs get way more mature because he
grows up as like a person D that's
pretty dop that's
awesome but that's why all these shows
have such a massive fan base and I feel
like like I'm not a part of it cuz I
always see everyone with the [__]
merch and the cool shirts and news is
you can start watching it anytime not
alone no dude people you could still
start and I want I want to get into it
but it's fck you want to feel included I
want to feel included I want to feel
inclusive this is your time what's yours
is yours Naruto she got a so I I
probably only watch maybe five uh
Naruto um parasite Death Note Death Note
Death Note is my favorite death not is a
top three God damn for me I would put
Death Note
narudo they're kind of side by side for
me neck to neck um kakagi is that how
you say it is it's a I know you're
talking about oh yeah yeah Kake [__]
yeah Kake guui or some [__] yeah
something like that it's with the it's
like you like mind games like you like
correct yeah um that one so yeah I I
would say those you would probably like
Love is War it's like a cuter like
romantic version of that style of like
there's their battling in their heads
and they attack on
oh that's yeah was bummer that show was
a bummer it's really good start getting
into that I tried to get into it and I
couldn't it made me
sad mom dude do you guys watch uh one
punch man that's that's one of my
favorites cuz everyone keeps telling me
you got to watch that's a satire it's
also it's also an anime lovers anime
yeah for sure wait you never saw a
perfect blue mm- that's your [__] that's
going to be your [__] 1 million per why
cuz it's it's not only a mind game anime
but it's a reference point for many of
today's
directors interesting not even in anime
but just scorsi like just people like
real
directors it had so many ideas
cinematically that get used that get
manifested into the physical world
because the guy that made created uh
perfect blue he he created it like it
was shot with a c so the perspective
that's what a lot of like um animes are
shot like if they were actually filmed
like in person like Aira Aira was done
her was a good one like that GH in the
sh was like that too a little bit Yeah
but it's like perfect blue is like
worshiped by like directors and [__] cuz
it's it's so [__] far ahead of its
time and it's a trip and it gets jacked
every year for another movie like people
steal the [__] out of that movie yeah I
like how they take a lot of like tropes
you would expect like oh people go on
adventure they fight for whatever but
then they have always have this twist to
it and that's like my favorite thing
about and it never you never run out of
content to watch dude with anim
honorable mentions Initial D oh yeah how
could you not yeah Roni Kenshin and
berserk B berser did you guys ever get
into bleach my brother got into that I
tried I couldn't do it I couldn't do it
why I wish I don't know I just didn't
grab me I just what's your take Anthony
Le it might just be a subjective thing
like you get into some things are a slow
build you need to get through like
[__] 10 episodes but I also didn't
get into Dragon Ball Z either like I
feel like Dragon Ball Z and bleach were
kind of like do you guys watch dubbed or
do you watch
subtitles it depends like there's some
series like City Hunter where dubbed is
actually really funny really cuz they
got good actors and it's like goofy as
hell and the way that they try to uh
translate the Japanese cultural
references is also kind of interesting
cuz there's some [__] that doesn't have
an English equivalent but they make one
and you're like what you know what I
mean yeah yeah you're right yeah you
guys want to know like some Modern
animes where it doesn't take any work to
get into like you watch it first episode
and you're like there's one called Juju
kaisen that's super good see reaction
right there season 2 just came out but
I'm waiting for it to all finish before
I can watch it I'm just waiting for all
the episodes to come out so I can just
binge it it's that good I heard that
name it's it's just like super good
animation um the story is really cool
and it's very it's got very very good
Swag yeah yeah yeah yeah who are like
the characters in it uh there's this guy
that's like I think his name is Yugi
itadori and and his he's just already
super strong high school kid and then he
joins this ghost Club ghost hunting club
oh and then later on like some real [__]
happens where there's actual like you
were tell me about yeah there's like
curses and stuff and then he learns how
to like like build this new power like
how to control curses and stuff it's
it's
crazy there's that there's a brand new
one that just came out called Z 100 you
should watch that one Z 100 yeah Z 100
is a it's a zombie anime but like the
animation is beautiful it's super good
did you watch High School of the Dead I
did I did I didn't finish it though but
that neither did the guy who made it oh
hey he passed
away
damn off now but definitely watch
[Music]
those